y
[Música]
el presidente de francés emmanuel
makhulong llegó a ruanda y en el
memorial del genocidio de 1994 aceptó la
responsabilidad seria y abrumadora de su
país por no prever la matanza de más de
800.000 tutsis y hutus moderados al
final de su discurso un grupo de
supervivientes del genocidio lamentó la
falta de una disculpa clara
a un día de completar un mes de
protestas el comité nacional del paro en
colombia sigue exigiendo que el gobierno
dé respuesta a su pliego de peticiones
incluyendo las denuncias de abuso
policial que siguen aumentando la noche
del miércoles de disturbios en bogotá
dejaron al menos 82 heridos en una
protesta que inició pacíficamente
y en india la segunda ola de la pandemia
que golpea al país con cifras récord de
contagios y muertes a diario se propaga
rápidamente en aldeas sin
infraestructura para atender la
emergencia ahora las escuelas y los
albergues son improvisados hospitales
ante el colapso del sistema sanitario
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y el mundo de visita en ruanda el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón
reconoció la responsabilidad de su país
en el genocidio que en 1994 dejó 800 mil
muertos tutsis y hutus moderados y pidió
a esta población el regalo del perdón
macrón estuvo en el memorial del
genocidio guisos y donde están
enterradas más de 250.000 personas
minutos después a sus discursos un grupo
de supervivientes lamentó la falta de
una disculpa clara del presidente galo
el informe es de juan pupiales
pocas veces hay tanta expectativa en
torno a un discurso como en esta ocasión
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
llegó a ruanda buscando normalizar las
relaciones con este país sus lazos han
estado marcados por las tensiones en
torno al papel de parís en el genocidio
de 1994 desde el memorial de kigali en
donde yacen los restos de más de 250.000
víctimas de las 800.000 que dejó el
génesis youtube si el mandatario admitió
la responsabilidad de francia
pero francia tiene un papel una historia
y una responsabilidad política en ruanda
y tiene un deber mirar la historia a la
cara y reconocer el sufrimiento que ha
infligido sobre el pueblo de ruanda al
permitir que el silencio prevalezca por
encima de la búsqueda de la verdad
durante mucho tiempo
francia es acusada de haber apoyado al
ejecutivo de la época con respaldo
logístico en marzo una comisión de
investigación de historiadores franceses
encontró que el país europeo tiene una
abrumadora responsabilidad por no haber
previsto la masacre
soy un joven lenin
son aquellos quienes han atravesado la
noche los que pueden quizás perdonar y
darnos el regalo del perdón los
son unas palabras que no son suficientes
para los supervivientes de la masacre
quienes lamentaron que el presidente
francés no haya pronunciado una disculpa
clara por su parte del presidente de
ruanda paul kagamé dio la bienvenida a
las palabras del presidente francés en
vez de criticarlo por no haber
pronunciado directamente la palabra
disculpa el líder africano aseguró que
los grandes podrían no olvidar pero sí
perdonar a francia por su papel en la
masacre
sus palabras fueron algo más valioso que
una disculpa a napoli they were fueron
la verdad
speaking the fruit hablar de la verdad
es arriesgado pero uno lo hace porque es
lo correcto
you know it de cosas
it is right en información de américa
latina' colombia se encuentra a un día
de cumplir un mes de manifestaciones
masivas contra el gobierno la noche de
este miércoles después de un día de
marchas pacíficas hubo disturbios en
bogotá hay al menos 82 personas
resultaron heridas luego de enfrentarse
con la policía entretanto el comité del
paro sigue pidiendo al presidente iván
duque una respuesta al pliego nacional
de emergencia y desde el interior del
país aumenta el llamado para que el
gobierno permita la entrada de
observadores internacionales mientras
las denuncias de abuso de la fuerza
siguen aumentando
natalia plazas informa
los reclamos al gobierno colombiano no
cesan cuando está a punto de cumplirse
un mes de protestas los manifestantes
rechazan que no se haya dado aún
respuesta a sus peticiones y tiran la
pelota al campo del ejecutivo para
terminar la crisis depende
fundamentalmente de que el gobierno
atienda esas peticiones y de alguna
manera la gente evalúe si se resuelven
los problemas sociales que tienen que
ver con el hambre con la pobreza con la
exclusión por ejemplo si tenemos una
renta básica otras exigencias son el
acceso universal a la educación superior
el desarme del escuadrón antidisturbios
y una reforma policial ante las
constantes denuncias de abusos de la
fuerza pública en las protestas la ong
local temblores resalta 60 asesinatos en
las manifestaciones 43 atribuidos a la
fuerza pública pero aún en esta
situación el gobierno es renuente a la
entrada de veedores internacionales
solicitamos al gobierno colombiano que
permita
entrada de la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos para que ellos en el
terreno se den cuenta que es lo que ha
ocurrido en nuestro país en cuanto a
violación de derechos humanos en contra
de declaraciones previas y tras la
presión la vicepresidenta a marta lucía
ramírez abrió la puerta a una entrada
anticipada de la comisión
en una ruptura con el gobierno nacional
la alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez
entregó un informe a la representante de
la alta comisionada de naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos sobre la
violencia ocurrida en la capital que
incluye la investigación de la muerte de
dos jóvenes por otro lado la corte
suprema del país hizo un llamado al cese
inmediato de la violencia después de que
una turba incendiara el palacio de
justicia del municipio de tuluá cercano
a la ciudad de cali epicentro de las
protestas las altas cortes no han
rechazado el uso desmedido de la fuerza
policial
para analizar lo que pasa en colombia
especialmente con los al menos 129
desaparecidos en este contexto nos
acompaña en luz marina monzones
directora de la unidad especial de
búsqueda de personas desaparecidas por
el conflicto en colombia buenos dias luz
marina usted ha trabajado en la defensa
de los derechos humanos durante más de
20 años 129 personas siguen
desaparecidas en el contexto de la
protesta según la fiscalía pero ong son
cifras mucho más altas a qué se debe
esta diferencia entre los reportes de
desaparecidos
buenos días muchísimas gracias por este
espacio a que se debe aún se debe a que
las cifras y le informa más que la cifra
la información no está disponible no
está organizada y no está accesible
entonces usted habla de 129 personas que
permanecen desaparecidas como bien lo
dice porque la fiscalía siglo reforma
sin embargo la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos ha recibido
información de 132 personas que
permanecen desaparecidas las
organizaciones del gasto si así por su
parte hablan de más de 200 personas han
llegado a mencionar más de 400 personas
desaparecidas durante el conflicto
durante este conflicto social
el motivo del paro
ustedes han pedido al estado colombiano
que se realice una búsqueda de
localización sin dilaciones de los
desaparecidos cuál ha sido la respuesta
del gobierno cómo está actuando para
ubicar a estas personas
bueno el yo creo que la fiscalía que es
la que tiene que desarrollar la tarea de
la búsqueda de las personas
desaparecidas no ha puesto a disposición
todos los mecanismos jurídicos que
existen para la protección hay
mecanismos como el mecanismo de búsqueda
urgente de personas desaparecidas las
organizaciones han presentado han
reclamado la activación de este
mecanismo y sin embargo este mecanismo
no ha sido aceptado en todas las
ocasiones pero por otro lado la
procuraduría general de la nación y las
personerías que son lentes de control
deben hacer una revisión de los
registros de detención de las personas y
esto no está funcionando adecuadamente y
creo que este es el mecanismo más
adecuado más cierto y más eficaz para
poder saber cuántas son las personas
detenidas si están o no lo están y en
qué lugares se encuentran y por lo tanto
saber sobre quiénes no se tiene
información no se sabe cuál es la suerte
cuál es el paradero de hecho
bueno y respecto a eso qué opinión les
merece a ustedes el hecho de que el
gobierno colombiano no haya permitido
hasta el momento del ingreso de la cdh
al país cómo puede afectar esto el
proceso de búsqueda
me parece que ante esta situación es
decir que no vengan los mejores ánimos
internacionales que son mecanismos que
fueron reconocidos por el estado cuando
hay asume la responsabilidad de dar
cumplimiento al tratado es un error es
un completo error porque porque una de
las tareas que tienen estos mecanismos
es justamente asesorar a los estados
para cumplir sus obligaciones una
presencia internacional puede apoyar la
búsqueda de soluciones por parte del
gobierno y las autoridades y en
definitiva contribuir a la protección de
los derechos y libertades de las
personas que se encuentran en altísimo
riesgo en este contexto y en el lado
humano de lo que representa este flagelo
qué mensaje le da la desaparición a la
ciudadanía a las familias que se están
viendo afectadas en un país donde
infortunadamente la violación de
derechos humanos es un pan diario desde
hace décadas
pues el mensaje es sumamente grave es
sumamente grave porque es la
reproducción de patrones del pasado que
llevaron a que hoy en colombia se hable
de más de 120 mil personas desaparecidas
durante el conflicto armado durante el
conflicto armado fueron desaparecidas
personas bajo patrones similares a lo
que estamos viendo hoy y es detenciones
por parte de agentes del estado a plena
luz del día sobre las cuales agentes
esos agentes del estado no dan cuenta de
a dónde fueron llevadas las personas las
familias no pueden acceder a información
rápidamente sobre lo que es sobre la
suerte de esa persona luego las personas
son llevadas a lugares que no
necesariamente son de detenciones
regulares como estaba ocurriendo en este
momento y esto el mensaje es que tenemos
que ser firmes como autoridades pero
también como sociedad en exigir que la
no repetición las personas no pueden ser
sometidas a desaparición forzada en este
país
en una parte del mundo muchas gracias a
usted y que aparezcan que es lo más
importante
continuamos con más noticias y vamos a
hablar ahora de kobe 19 el segundo
estado más poblado de australia victoria
entrará en un nuevo bloqueo por covite
durante una semana lo que obligará a sus
casi siete millones de residentes a
permanecer en casa a menos que
argumenten asuntos esenciales las
autoridades luchan por contener el brote
altamente infeccioso los rastreadores
han identificado más de 10 mil contactos
primarios y secundarios que necesitarían
ponerse en cuarentena hacerse pruebas y
aislar se agregaron que ese número
seguirá creciendo y cambiando
en india la segunda ola de la pandemia
que ha dejado recursos diarios de
contagios y muertes ahora comienza a
propagarse en las aldeas mal equipadas
para atender esta emergencia el número
de muertes en india es el tercero más
alto del mundo sólo después de eeuu y
brasil y representa 86 por ciento de las
muertes a nivel global en comunidades
remotas del país los ciudadanos se las
ingenian para hacer frente a la
emergencia de salud jorge hurtado con el
reporte
la pandemia se ensaña con las aldeas y
pequeños poblados de india en el estado
indio de gujarat los habitantes
decidieron convertir albergues y
escuelas en improvisadas clínicas ante
el colapso del sistema hospitalario hay
13 pacientes en el centro de atención
junco y 19 desde ahora se van a curar y
serán dados de alta pronto el mayor
logro para nosotros es que los últimos
30 días ningún paciente ha muerto ante
la falta de camas en hospitales este
improvisado centro atiende a adultos
mayores de 45 años más de 80 han sido
enviados a casa totalmente recuperados
pero en otros estados como utah arakan
donde no existe la mínima
infraestructura para proponer centros
temporales unidades móviles de salud
deben subir empinadas montañas para
intentar atender a los contagiados con
los escasos medios disponibles hay
muchas instalaciones disponibles aquí
como puede ver aquí ni siquiera hay
electricidad el oxígeno tampoco funciona
uno de los cilindros está vacío y solo
tenemos otro adicional
en la remota aldea de pita frontera con
nepal y china los aldeanos deben
realizarse la prueba del cofipe
pero es que va a jugar los aldeanos
tienen miedo de lo que les sucedería si
dan positivo tendríamos que viajar a un
hospital muy lejano y las noticias dicen
que están repletos ya que en ella india
registrado 26 millones de casos y es el
segundo epicentro de la pandemia a nivel
mundial hasta ahora registra más de
300.000 fallecidos por kobe aunque
analistas apuntan que esa cifra podría
ser mayor debido a los subregistros
extraer el movimiento islamista hamás
aceptaron reunirse la próxima semana en
el cairo para afianzar la tregua de ese
es el fuego acordada hace una semana con
la mediación de egipto y abordar temas
como la reconstrucción de gaza o el
intercambio de rehenes mientras tanto la
alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos michelle bachelet dijo
que los ataques hacia casas siembran
dudas sobre el cumplimiento israelí de
los principios de distinción y
proporcionalidad en la ley humanitaria
internacional y que si se demuestra que
fueron de indiscriminados y
desproporcionados tales ataques podrían
constituir crímenes de guerra
y un sindicato de médicos japoneses
advirtió que la celebración de los
juegos olímpicos en tokio este verano
podría conducir al desarrollo de una
nueva cepa olímpica del coronavirus
japón lucha por contener la cuarta ola
de la pandemia y se prepara para
extender un estado de emergencia naoto
ue llamado director de la unión de
médicos japoneses reclamó que para ganar
la batalla contra el coronavirus hay que
detener el movimiento y cancelar las
competencias que reúnen a más de 200
naciones
hasta aquí el informativo continúe con
nosotros ya volvemos con más
[Música]